Would you ever take a pay cut for a job that look worse on paper? Because we're taught to think that career progress means more money, a better title and a step up. But some of the most important moves I've made in my career have been sideways, and one of the moves took me entirely away from psychology for almost two years. So how do you know when a move that feels like it might be backwards or possibly sideways has potential to take you forwards. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent and this is Psychology Actually. Hi, welcome along to Psychology Actually. I am Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. It's really lovely to have you here. I was inspired to do this episode after seeing a Reddit post
你是否愿意为了一个纸面上看起来更差的工作而接受减薪？因为我们被教导认为职业进步意味着更多的钱、更好的头衔和更上一层楼。但我职业生涯中做出的一些最重要的举动都是横向的，其中一个举动甚至让我离开了心理学领域近两年。那么，你如何判断一个看起来像是倒退或横向的举动是否具有让你前进的潜力呢？我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，这是《心理学实际上》。嗨，欢迎来到《心理学实际上》。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。很高兴你能来到这里。在看到一篇Reddit帖子后，我受到了启发，决定制作这一集。
and it really made me think about so many aspects of my own career, my own journey and that of supporting qualified psychologists, even advising people outside of psychology roles, when they're considering what they're going to do for work, what they should apply for, whether they should go for interviews. And I thought it might be useful to have a conversation about that here with you. So the post, in a nutshell, was that someone had found themselves in a Band 5 NHS assistant psychologist role. I've been there for almost 18 months. And now they're sort of at that point where they're like,
它确实让我思考了自己职业生涯、个人旅程以及支持合格心理学家的许多方面，甚至在为心理学领域之外的人提供建议时，当他们考虑自己要做什么工作、应该申请什么职位、是否应该去面试时。我想在这里和你讨论一下这个问题可能很有用。简而言之，这篇帖子的内容是，有人发现自己处于NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）的5级助理心理学家职位上。我已经在这个职位上待了近18个月了。现在他们处于那种状态，他们觉得，
I think it's time to move on, but I'm not really seeing any other band five roles. I'm seeing maybe lots of band four roles start to come up. But I'm used to the money, and then I also used to get travel, so that kind of boosted it a little bit. And I'm not really sure what to do. So I guess I've got a couple of thoughts around that.
我想是时候离开了，但我并没有看到其他5级职位。我看到可能有很多4级职位开始出现。但我习惯了现在的薪水，而且我过去还有差旅费，所以这稍微增加了一点收入。我真的不知道该怎么办。所以我想我对此有几个想法。
And firstly, it's when you're looking to progress in your career, it might well be that you feel like really, in order to stand out on an application form, I'm probably going to need to get some extra skills, some extra experience, some enhanced level of depth of understanding on what I'm already doing that I think maybe, I might have reached the plateau for in my current role. And believe me, that does happen. And at that point, you might be like, could I do some other bits in this role? Could I speak to my manager? Could I think about doing, I don't know, some service or some audit or taking on a special project that helps me to gain more skills and experience?
首先，当你寻求职业进步时，你可能会觉得，为了在申请表上脱颖而出，我可能需要获得一些额外的技能、一些额外的经验、对我已经在做的事情有更深入的理解，而我认为在目前的职位上可能已经达到了瓶颈。相信我，这种情况确实会发生。在那一点上，你可能会想，我能在现在的职位上做些其他事情吗？我能和我的经理谈谈吗？我能考虑做些什么，我不知道，比如一些服务或审计，或者承担一个能帮助我获得更多技能和经验的特殊项目吗？
Maybe I might be able to start supervising a member of staff. Maybe I might be able to start putting together a group and then running that in conjunction with someone who might be qualified or another member of the team or even shadowing some different kind of different members of the MDT team if you're in that sort of service, that sort of role, so that you can really feel like you are still being shaped, you're still growing, you're still learning because I don't think is anything more stagnating than feeling like you're not. really getting anything new. Now of course energy-wise, sometimes that suits us. So when I was just back from having my second baby and when I was kind of going through some grief stuff with
也许我能开始监督一名员工。也许我能开始组建一个小组，然后与可能合格的人或团队中的其他成员一起运行它，甚至如果是在那种服务或职位中，跟随MDT（多学科团队）的不同成员进行观察，这样你就能真正感觉到你仍然在被塑造，你仍然在成长，你仍然在学习，因为我认为没有什么比感觉自己没有学到任何新东西更停滞不前的了。当然，从精力上讲，有时这很适合我们。所以当我刚生完第二个孩子回来，当我经历一些关于
my dad, then energy-wise I probably wouldn't have been wanting to do things that were a very steep learning curve for me. So a little bit of variety was okay, but actually I didn't have the resources personally at that time to be doing more. You, might feel different. You might be like I've got all this energy, I've got all this enthusiasm, but I've either reached the plateau for this job, or when I'm asking for more roles, when I'm asking for more responsibility, when I'm asking for a little bit of kind of flavour and variety in the work that I'm doing, for whatever reason that isn't coming to me. You then get to decide, well, what am I going to do about that? Am I going to look elsewhere? And of course,
我父亲的悲伤事情时，从精力上讲，我可能不想做那些对我来说学习曲线非常陡峭的事情。所以有一点变化是可以的，但实际上我当时个人没有资源去做更多的事情。你可能会有不同的感觉。你可能会想，我有所有的精力，我有所有的热情，但我要么已经达到了这份工作的瓶颈，要么当我要求更多角色、更多责任、更多工作乐趣和多样性时，无论出于什么原因，这些都没有到来。然后你就可以决定，好吧，我要对此做些什么？我要去别处看看吗？当然，
none of us are in this to work for free. Even though we genuinely care about people, if we're working in mental health, I would hope that you're genuinely move by the distress of others. Because really, I think when we're working in mental health, that is really important because the money is not always amazing, right? So you have to have another why. But of course, if you've got fixed cost bills to pay, maybe your mortgage, your rent, you know, your travel costs, you might even have dependents that you need to help support or solely support, then actually dropping down from a band five role or a band seven role to a band six role to do training, that is and can be a very big consideration. Now with the current cost of living crisis,
我们没有人是为了免费工作而做这些的。即使我们真心关心他人，如果我们从事心理健康工作，我希望你是真心被他人的痛苦所触动。因为真的，我认为当我们从事心理健康工作时，这非常重要，因为钱并不总是那么丰厚，对吧？所以你必须有另一个理由。但当然，如果你有固定的账单要付，比如你的抵押贷款、房租，你知道，你的差旅费，你甚至可能有需要帮助抚养或独自抚养的家属，那么实际上从5级或7级职位降到6级职位去接受培训，这确实是一个非常大的考虑因素。现在随着当前的生活成本危机，
then of course if you have been getting travel reimbursements, I don't think we're getting much more than actually the cost of the fuel at the moment. So if you're going to be in a base where you are not travelling, you're just going to your place of work, and then you're going home at the end of the day, then actually, if you're spending less on fuel, that kind of travel expense might not feature as much for you. It might just be like a psychological norm that you're used to seeing a certain amount of money come in, but of course some of that will have been money going out because you've had to pay for parking costs. You've had to pay for your fuel for your trips to get out and see your clients. Some of it might be a bit lifestyle
那么当然，如果你一直得到差旅报销，我不认为我们目前得到的比实际燃油成本多多少。所以如果你在一个不需要出差的基地，你只是去你的工作地点，然后在一天结束时回家，那么实际上，如果你在燃油上的花费更少，那种差旅费可能对你来说就不那么重要了。这可能只是你习惯看到一定金额收入的一种心理常态，但当然其中一些钱是流出的，因为你必须支付停车费。你必须支付去见客户的燃油费。其中一些可能也与生活方式有关
as well. Maybe if you are out and about, you're used to being able to work in an agile manner or work from home sometimes. And so some of that might be a little bit of a culture change to you as well. When I was freshly graduated from university, I actually took a completely unrelated role because I needed to prioritise my own needs above my career needs. So at that time, I was saving up to go travelling. So my primary concern was being able to be in a role where I could do as many hours as possible at a higher hourly rate than I'd already been on. So I was a home carer and I absolutely loved that work. But I couldn't suddenly invent more home care clients for the company. And so I kind of left the industry all together and then started.
。也许如果你经常外出，你习惯于以灵活的方式工作或有时在家工作。所以其中一些对你来说可能也是一种文化变革。当我刚从大学毕业时，我实际上从事了一个完全不相关的角色，因为我需要优先考虑自己的需求而不是职业需求。所以当时，我正在存钱去旅行。所以我主要关心的是能够从事一份能以比我之前更高的时薪工作尽可能多小时的角色。所以我是一名家庭护理员，我非常喜欢那份工作。但我不能突然为公司创造更多的家庭护理客户。所以我基本上完全离开了这个行业，然后开始
doing work as a temp worker in office buildings in Milton Keynes and the money for that was higher as an hourly rate and it also meant longer days so I was working nine I think until 6pm so long days and then there was also the potential to do overtime on a Saturday as well so that really did boost my income which then allowed me to save to be able to have the six months off to go around the world and that was you know of priority for me but it did mean I took almost two years out of what I was doing until I then found my way back into a relevant role because actually as soon as I got back from travelling, I went back to doing that temp work but someone had offered me a permanent job. So I went back to one of the teams that I'd been in,
在米尔顿凯恩斯的办公楼里做临时工，那份工作的时薪更高，而且意味着工作时间更长，所以我工作到我想是下午6点，所以工作时间很长，而且周六还有加班的可能，这确实增加了我的收入，这让我能够存钱，从而有六个月的时间去环游世界，那是，你知道，我的首要任务，但这确实意味着我从我正在做的事情中抽出了近两年时间，直到我后来找到了回到相关角色的路，因为实际上我一从旅行回来，我就回去做那些临时工作，但有人给了我一份永久工作。所以我回到了我曾经所在的团队之一，
but I do not consider that wasted time. I consider that personal enrichment development, personal development for me and stuff that actually still really helps me on tricky days is reflecting on some of those incredible memories that I had when I was in my early 20s. I think something else that might be helpful to say is my experience of working as, for example, an assistant psychologist in a team is that often I felt like I was doing work that was higher up than kind of the band four I was doing. And a lot of the roles I was seeing advertised were maybe, you know, suitable for about than five people to be doing. but for whatever reason they were just banned four roles.
但我并不认为那是浪费时间。我认为那是个人充实发展，对我来说是个人发展，而且在棘手的日子里，回顾我20多岁时那些不可思议的记忆，确实对我很有帮助。我认为还有一点可能有帮助的是，我作为团队中的助理心理学家的工作经验是，我经常觉得我在做比我所做的4级职位更高层级的工作。而且我看到很多招聘广告中的角色可能，你知道，适合5级的人去做。但无论出于什么原因，它们只是4级职位。
So please don't think that it's like a demotion if you're applying for a band four role. And I know pay wise it might feel that way. But similarly, I've worked in band seven roles that really I was ready to be at an 8A, but there wasn't the budget to be able to kind of support a preceptorship shift. So it might be that you're in a role at the moment where you are gaining that seniority of experience, if you're looking at your key performance indicators, that you are gaining some of the skills that you would be able to say, well, I am at that level, but for whatever reason, there isn't the budget there to support that. So try not to be too led on the bandings, is what I would say.
所以请不要认为如果你申请4级职位就是降职。我知道在薪水方面可能会有这种感觉。但同样，我曾在7级职位工作过，实际上我已经准备好达到8A级了，但没有预算来支持这种职前培训的转变。所以可能你目前处于一个正在获得资深经验的职位，如果你看看你的关键绩效指标，你正在获得一些技能，你可以说，好吧，我已经达到了那个水平，但无论出于什么原因，没有预算来支持这一点。所以我想说的是，尽量不要太受职级的影响。
That said, of course, if you find yourself in a role where you're doing things vastly above your spine point, then do discuss that with your manager and your supervisor to consider whether rebranding might be an option or whether actually someone else in the team should be doing some of those roles. I think also it can be helpful to think about the kind of different reasons why we might want to optimise our career. And broadly speaking, I think they are. Money, learning, time, well-being, relationships and future options. So for me, it was not a case that I could always keep all six of those kind of ducks in a row, but it's allowing myself to prioritise one or two of those at any given time. And that might suit me for now, but it might not necessarily suit me forever. So it's
话虽如此，当然，如果你发现自己处于一个工作内容远高于你职级水平的职位，那么请务必与你的经理和主管讨论，考虑是否可以重新定级，或者团队中是否应该有其他人来承担这些角色。我认为思考我们为什么要优化职业生涯的不同原因也很有帮助。广义上讲，我认为它们是：金钱、学习、时间、幸福感、人际关系和未来选择。所以对我来说，并不是我总能把这六个方面都照顾好，而是允许自己在任何特定时间优先考虑其中一两个。这可能暂时适合我，但不一定永远适合我。所以这是
really empowering myself to make the choice for whatever version of myself is present at this time. So like I said, if I'd been looking for new roles when I'd just lost my dad, then it might have been I'd prioritise a role that was higher paid so I could perhaps do fewer days a week and that was close to home so that it didn't impact on my relationships and didn't take me too long to get to. I would love your thoughts on this. How are you juggling your six components? Do let me know in the comments whether you're watching on YouTube or on Spotify. And people have been like, why don't you ever mention Apple Podcasts? I know lots of you listen on Apple Podcasts as well, but currently there isn't a facility to be able to drop episode-specific comments, but there is an opportunity
真正赋予自己权力，为此时此刻的自己做出选择。所以就像我说的，如果我刚失去父亲时在寻找新职位，那么我可能会优先考虑一份薪水更高的职位，这样我每周可以少工作几天，而且离家近，这样就不会影响我的人际关系，也不会花太长时间去上班。我很想听听你对此的想法。你是如何平衡这六个要素的？无论你是在YouTube还是Spotify上观看，请在评论中告诉我。人们一直问，为什么你从不提Apple Podcasts？我知道你们很多人也在Apple Podcasts上收听，但目前还没有提供针对特定剧集发表评论的功能，但有一个机会
for you to rate and review the show. So if you're listening on your phone, if you go to the show and then scroll down, and then you can click read reviews and write a review. I would be so very grateful. I think there can be a pressure to think, I need to know everything, I need to know everything. And I think it's that kind of juggle of breadth of experience versus depth of experience. And so it might just be worth a quick check-in with actually, am I putting pressure on myself to know all of these things, or could I give myself permission to really, you know, really go deeper on my knowledge and my skills in this area? So to focus on my depth of experience. Because believe me, at interview, if you've got depth of experience when you're asked a
让你给节目评分和评论。所以如果你在手机上收听，如果你进入节目然后向下滚动，你就可以点击阅读评论并写下评论。我会非常感激。我认为人们可能会有一种压力，觉得我需要知道一切，我需要知道一切。我认为这就是广度经验与深度经验之间的平衡。所以可能值得快速检查一下，我是否在给自己压力去了解所有这些事情，或者我能否给自己许可去真正地，你知道，真正深入了解我在这个领域的知识和技能？所以专注于我的深度经验。因为相信我，在面试时，如果你有深度经验，当被问到一个
question, you'll be able to just, you know, give a really lovely answer rather than then trying to scrabble around for something that seems like it makes sense. I know also when speaking to people about pay. Sometimes when you change to a different role, sometimes especially if you're going to a more senior role, there can then be the expectation that any overtime that you do is just part of the job. And of course, we don't necessarily want you to be losing money from doing shift allowances or shift enhancements or from time and a half that you might have been earning from doing overtime. So all of these are important things to consider as well, of course, course, of any pension implications. So we should be thinking about our pensions, even if you
问题时，你将能够，你知道，给出一个非常好的答案，而不是试图拼凑一些看起来合理的东西。我也知道在谈论薪水时。有时当你换到不同的职位时，有时特别是如果你去了一个更高级的职位，可能会有一种期望，即你所做的任何加班都只是工作的一部分。当然，我们不一定希望你因为失去轮班津贴或轮班增强费，或者因为加班可能赚到的1.5倍工资而损失金钱。所以所有这些也都是需要考虑的重要事项，当然，还有任何养老金的影响。所以我们应该考虑我们的养老金，即使你
were younger. I wish I'd been savvy enough to start investing when I was in my 20s. One of my friends was a pension advisor at the time. And I remember just thinking, oh, how boring. How boring. But I wish I'd listen to him because I would be significantly better off than I am now. If that sounds intriguing to you, please do check out two episodes I did with Ian Dempsey, who is a financial advisor. I often think when you're trying to make a decision, you can't go far wrong with opening up a notebook. I like my remarkable notebook, but you might actually prefer pen and paper, and scribbling down
还年轻。我希望我在20多岁时足够精明，开始投资。我的一位朋友当时是养老金顾问。我记得我当时只是想，哦，多无聊啊。多无聊啊。但我希望我听了他的话，因为我现在会比现在好得多。如果这听起来让你感兴趣，请务必查看我与财务顾问伊恩·邓普西做的两集节目。我经常认为当你试图做出决定时，打开一个笔记本不会出错。我喜欢我的Remarkable笔记本，但你可能更喜欢纸和笔，并写下
your answers to some questions. If you don't like writing, you might find it helpful to drop yourself voice notes, perhaps on WhatsApp. That's my favourite place to drop myself memos. And I think some good questions to mull over are these. What will I genuinely gain from this move? What will I genuinely lose from this move? Am I still developing where I'm currently working?
你对一些问题的回答。如果你不喜欢写作，你可能会发现给自己发语音笔记很有帮助，也许是在WhatsApp上。那是我给自己留备忘录最喜欢的地方。我认为一些值得深思的好问题是这些：我从这次变动中真正能获得什么？我从这次变动中真正会失去什么？我在目前工作的地方还在发展吗？
What does my life need from my job right now? If nobody could see my job title or my salary, which role will I actually choose? And seeing as this is a pretty good reflective journal exercise, let's drop in one more for you to consider as well. Am I making this move because it genuinely is going to help me or because I'm frightened that my existing experience isn't enough? If it's the latter, you might find it helpful to talk to someone supportive, a supervisor, a manager, someone else who knows your position and understands the context in which you work. Because of course, we can't know that that is a genuine, genuine opinion that our brain is serving us up.
我的生活现在需要我的工作提供什么？如果没人能看到我的职位头衔或薪水，我会选择哪个职位？鉴于这是一个非常好的反思日记练习，让我们再加一个供你考虑的问题。我做出这个变动是因为它真的会帮助我，还是因为我害怕我现有的经验不够？如果是后者，你可能会发现与支持你的人交谈很有帮助，比如主管、经理，或者其他了解你的立场并理解你工作背景的人。因为当然，我们不能确定那确实是我们大脑提供给我们的真实观点。
It might just be a lot of fear, there might not necessarily be too much evidence for you to draw that conclusion. So I often think that getting a second opinion from someone that you genuinely trust and has insight into your situation is a really good idea. That said, if your career of choice is psychology and you're striving for the doctorate in clinical psychology, why not check out the aspiring psychologist membership, which you can join from just £30 a month with no minimum term. I do also offer therapy and coaching sessions too. So even if your career of choice is not psychology, I might still be able to help you to achieve your goals. So in summary, I think what I'd say is that our careers don't always move in kind of forward increments. It's not always a neat, linear upwards trajectory.
那可能只是很多恐惧，不一定有太多的证据让你得出那个结论。所以我经常认为从你真正信任且对你的情况有洞察力的人那里获得第二意见是一个非常好的主意。话虽如此，如果你的职业选择是心理学，并且你正在努力攻读临床心理学博士学位，为什么不看看“有抱负的心理学家会员资格”呢？你只需每月30英镑即可加入，没有最低期限。我也提供治疗和辅导课程。所以即使你的职业选择不是心理学，我也可能仍然能帮助你实现目标。总之，我想说的是，我们的职业生涯并不总是以向前的增量移动。它并不总是一条整洁、线性的向上轨迹。
Sometimes the right move for you will be sideways. Sometimes it might pay less if you can afford for that to happen. Sometimes you might feel that the job title doesn't maybe sound. that impressive and sometimes like I did sometimes it might take you away from your ultimate career goal but hopefully you're doing that for a very important reason and I think it's with hindsight when we look back on our journeys that we sometimes see just how important those sideways or different moves were for us being where we are right now the sense we made of that what we learned about ourselves on the way
有时对你来说正确的举动是横向的。有时如果负担得起，薪水可能会更低。有时你可能会觉得职位头衔听起来可能没那么令人印象深刻，有时就像我一样，有时它可能会让你偏离最终的职业目标，但希望你这样做是有非常重要的原因的。我认为当我们回顾自己的旅程时，有时会看到那些横向或不同的举动对于我们现在所处的位置有多么重要，我们从中得出的意义，以及我们在途中学到的关于自己的东西。
there I would absolutely love your thoughts on this please do draw drop me a comment on YouTube or on Spotify and please do follow the show or subscribe to the show wherever you watch or get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我非常想听听你对此的想法，请务必在YouTube或Spotify上给我留言，并请在任何你观看或获取播客的地方关注或订阅该节目。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。